this week on world stories Gaza caught
in the middle
Cape Verde fighting alcohol abuse but
first to Britain where one year ago the
electorate voted to leave the EU in a
contentious referendum but what do
people think now
and stay in eating he might look like
the British Foreign Secretary but drew
Gordon is decidedly anti brexit he's
campaigning with other Londoners to keep
Britain in the European Union his goal
have another referendum and put the
question again - to the British people
leave one the previous referendum on the
basis of on the basis of lies told by
leave campaign most of the people in
this group including Gareth Williams and
IT consultant only got involved in the
issue after last year's referendum now
he's out three times a week you're
basically saying look we're here we're
not going away you know our voice still
counts it's the process isn't over it's
still going to be nearly another two
years but this group of activists is
hardly representative of the wider
public and it hasn't been easy winning
people over opinion poll suggests most
Brits who voted to leave the EU last
June hadn't changed their minds there
isn't any evidence of any clear major
significant change in the balance of
opinion this is a country that divided
over brexit and this is a country that
still divided over brexit twelve months
later voters and Rumford on the eastern
outskirts of London overwhelmingly
favored brexit in last year's vote Tony
Geary is just as NTEU now as he was then
there's too many people in this country
don't matter what color what race what
size they are there's too many people
and we've got to stop more people coming
in because we were seen halting
immigration seems more important than
the possible economic consequences of
Britain's leaving the EU some traders
are already dealing with higher
wholesale prices I've lost that slightly
but in the longer run I think it's for
the benefit of the country and for me as
a business
but even some brexit ears and Rumford
are getting anxious about the Prime
Minister's negotiating tactics it's just
gonna be a hard fight you ain't gonna be
easy as they fall and don't feature
after you go by the situation No Deal
we pull out she's got to be a little bit
softer but not too soft the front lines
have not shifted that much but the
battle over Europe is far from over
[Music]
the Gaza Strip receives much of its
electricity from the Israeli grid but a
dispute over who should pay the bill has
resulted in daily power cuts residents
often have to make do with as little as
two hours of power a day
[Music]
a quick phone call to a colleague nearby
everyone in the neighborhood is waiting
for an electricity worker to arrive with
the flick of a switch they turn off the
power in one neighborhood and power up
somewhere else
Gaza is getting very little electricity
from the Israeli grid colicky was
waiting for a call from someone at the
eastern line to switch on the
electricity he just shut off the
connection from the western side because
this neighborhood's turn is over just a
few streets away miser Sultan hurries to
fill the washing machine her
neighborhood has electricity again but
only for a precious three hours a day
all of that in the middle of the summer
when the electricity comes on I start
washing my laundry and do anything else
I need energy for I have to do this all
very quickly the makeshift battery
system which supplies a little light
during a blackout also needs to be
charged nothing works
refrigerators water pumps elevators last
week the two million inhabitants of Gaza
had to make do with as little as two
hours of power every day the situation
here is going from bad to worse but if
our self-proclaimed leaders in Gaza and
the West Bank would just consider more
than their own interest and finally take
the wishes of the people into account
then something might change Gaza has
been blockaded by Israel and Egypt for
more than a decade in April causes only
power plant had to be shut down due to a
lack of fuel since then Gaza has
depended on energy from Egypt and Israel
but last week Israel reduced its
electricity supply at the request of
Palestinian President Mahmoud Abbas
he no longer wants to pay the power bill
for the Gaza Strip which is controlled
by his rival Hamas Al Bateen
Hamas needs to respond to the initiative
of the president by handing over the
border crossings reverting from it Skoob
and handing over all institutions to the
government of national consensus for the
last several years Hamas has received
funding for streets hospitals and even
fuel from cotta but Kanta is having
problems of its own and pressures
growing on Hamas on Gaza coast one can
smell the fallout of the crisis long
before one sees it
sewage flushed into the sea treatment
plants don't have enough power to work
properly the dirty water flows north
towards Israel and although Egypt
recently delivered a small amount of
fuel to the Gaza Strip that shipment was
just a drop in the ocean in an ever
worsening crisis
election year in Germany and we are
traveling to the country to gauge the
mood this week we stopped off in Bavaria
to visit Vick Scheid a small border town
that two years ago witnessed the arrival
of thousands of refugees
school is out for Diana Juma it's time
to go home the ahjummas are one of four
Syrian families living the small town of
vague shite near the Austrian border
Mahmoud cofrin and their two daughters
are considered a model of good
integration the girls speak perfect
German even though they've only been
here a year their parents are learning
the language and finding work where they
can they were welcomed with open arms
and they still feel at home in fiction
but the atmosphere has changed they say
and politics is to blame I want to ask
politicians in Germany are we refugees
or should we integrate if we should
integrate that means in time we would be
like Germans and that means we would not
be refugees anymore will they be able to
call Germany home in the long term they
say the uncertainty is discouraging it
all looked different just two years ago
at the height of the refugee crisis in
2015
around 4,000 migrants and refugees tried
to cross into Germany here in vague hide
every day more than 60,000 people
arrived in just six weeks
leaving authorities scrambling it was a
logistical nightmare and they only just
managed thanks to local volunteers who
jumped in to help some of them are still
active today like throny Huckle
her company builds high-quality beds
they hired Ephram from Eritrea who has
been granted asylum throny also works at
IC unit and Passau they guide companies
through the process of
internationalization Massey is their IT
expert he and his family arrived here in
2013 from head up in Afghanistan they
have been granted refugee status but his
future hangs in the balance his asylum
application was denied he has an
extension for the next year while Syrian
and Eritrean refugees are
certain to be granted asylum Afghan
refugees are increasingly facing
deportation the through solidarity for
Massey is huge not only because the
situation is so absurd but also because
it's so personal for us Gate back at the
workshop
throny says for now Massey and ephraim
are safe but their futures are uncertain
they say they need a clear signal from
the government to know whether they
really are welcome in Germany
according to the World Health
Organization alcoholism has become a
serious health threat in Cape Verde and
is hampering development in this West
African country we talked with one man
helping recovering alcoholics
[Music]
this wood was going to be thrown away
now John Nelson Fernandez is using his
carpentry skills to make it into a
cupboard nine months ago he was
struggling with alcoholism then he came
for help at El Shaddai tents a rehab
center in southern Cape Verde now he
works from dawn till dusk seven days a
week the cupboard is a gift for his
mother Amy Odom with a media personality
minty Basanti conceal she helped me very
much she told me to stop drinking
alcohol to overcome this addiction she
supported me a lot and advised me now
that I'm here in this rehab center I
think she'll be very happy with what I'm
doing for her with the finish corner
prayer when he was younger general Tsin
dreamt of being a lawyer but at the age
of 19 he started drinking later things
got out of hand John Olsen punched his
brother and was ordered to pay a fine he
couldn't afford he then started drinking
heavily and spent all his money on
alcohol at El Shaddai tents there are
strict rules all 40 residents of the
center are woken up at 6:30 in the
morning after morning prayers and
breakfast they start work
there's bread to be baked and some at
the rehab center work on the organic
farm which provides food for the
residents whatever's left is sold in a
nearby village the profits come back to
the rehab center or nori off regatta
founded it in 1996 the 68 year old says
there's a lot more work to be done
what's the main cause of death and
capered alcoholism what's the number-one
cause of car accidents alcoholism what's
behind gender-based violence and broken
families alcoholism many patients stay
here after their recovery because they
can't find a job John Nelson Fernandez
is among those struggling to leave al
Shaddai he hasn't given up hope of
making a living through carpentry to
take care of his family
[Music]
you
[Music]